Good afternoon, Hall and Wood Finance. Laura speaking, how can I help you?
Hi. I would like to add an overdraft facility to my account, please.
That's absolutely fine. And what is your account number and your account name?
CF. Mm-hmm.
2-1.
4-5.
7-8.
Fabulous, I can see the year. And what's the account name, please?
James Pinkham.
Fabulous. I can see you here, James.
That is absolutely fine.
What amount of overdraft would you like to actually put on your account?
Well, what's the best you can give me?
I mean, like, I need about 1,500 or something like that.
Is that OK?
Yeah, that's absolutely fine. 1,500.
Actually, it's day and year because you've been with us for so long,
I can actually offer you a six-month interest-free period.
You're joking.
No, absolutely.
Just as a long-list tea kind of thing,
because you've been with us for quite a while now, haven't you?
Yeah.
We'd like to reward our existing customers.
So, yes, I can actually extend that overdraft for you
for a six-month interest-free period.
Well, that'd be fantastic if you could, yeah.
That'd be great.
Absolutely no problem. I'd love to do that for you.
So, that is all set up for you now to be able to use that.
If you just give it like an hour or two, just a vessel,
and then that will be there all for you.
That's brilliant. Thanks so much.
Thank you so much for that. I wasn't expecting that.
That's amazing.
No, it's a major day, haven't I?
No, like I said.
Well, have a lovely day. Anything else that you need from me?
No, that's all. Thank you. Thank you so much.
No worries. Have a lovely day and enjoy your overdraft.
Thank you. See you later.
No, bye. Bye.